la parole la parole est à madame
marianne dubois
merci monsieur le président avant de
poser ma question premier ministre je
voulais peut rebondir sur la question
qu'a posé mon collègue marceau et
voulons voulez savoir quand aurait lieu
exactement l'expulsion de du monsieur
meira monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur s'il vous plaît la
semaine passée dans le plus grand secret
nous avons découvert à la lecture du
journal officiel un arrêté en date du 14
mai dernier aussi surprenant que
consternant diminuait la moitié du taux
annuel de l'aide de la bourse au mérite
passant ainsi de 1800 euros à 900 euros
il est précisé que les étudiants
boursiers déjà bénéficiaires de cette
aide en 2014 et 2015 toucheront 1800
euros
mais ceux qui passent leur bac en 2015
ne toucheront plus que 900 euros alors
que des députés de tous les bancs
s'étaient mobilisés pour défendre la
jeunesse méritante
une circulaire du ministère de
l'éducation nationale publié le 26
février au bulletin officiel annonçait
le rétablissement de la bourse au mérite
accordée aux jeunes bacheliers se
obtenant une mention très bien au
baccalauréat 2015 à condition d'avoir
également droit à une bourse sur
critères sociaux
est il besoin de rappeler qu'en juillet
dernier le ministère de l'éducation
nationale avait programmé la suppression
progressive de cette bourse dans le
cadre d'un redéploiement des aides
étudiantes
mais en octobre 2014 concédait à vous
rappeler à l'ordre en suspendant
provisoirement cette disposition sur le
fondement d'un doute sérieux quant à sa
légalité
ce qui vous a d'ailleurs conduit à
rétablir cette bourse monsieur le
premier ministre vous qui n'avez de
cesse de parler de l'égalité
républicaine
cette décision est un mauvais signal
envoyé à notre jeunesse qui veut réussir
qui veut parfaire son parcours scolaire
et pour s'insérer dans notre société
nous regrettons votre attitude est votre
choix arbitraire et nous vous demandons
solennellement de revenir sur votre
décision à quinze jours des épreuves du
baccalauréat
merci la palette à madame najat vallaud
belkacem ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
du bois je prends note de votre
sollicitude à l'égard des étudiants je
ne doute pas qu'elle ira droit au coeur
de ceux qui ont attendu pendant des
années vainement que vous leur versier
le dixième mois de bourse que vous leur
avez premier est jamais financé de ceux
qui ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat ça fait
c'est la pauvreté et le logement les
envahir ces dernières années au point
que certains d'entre eux ont renoncé à
faire des études ou renoncer à se
soigner sans que cela à ma connaissance
vous est ému outre mesure vont commenter
donc notre politique de bourse je veux
bien mais je le confirme
madame dubois nous n'avons pas la même
politique que vous il ne s'agit pour
nous ni de faire la charité ni deux nous
exonérer à bon compte de nos
responsabilités à l'égard de tous les
étudiants en nous contentant d'en aider
quelques uns pour se donner bonne
conscience alors oui ça vous un
visiblement échappé depuis 2012 ce
gouvernement a investi 450 millions
d'euros dans les bourses étudiantes 450
millions d'euros supplémentaires qui ont
permis par exemple bd 130 mille
étudiants supplémentaires de classe
moyenne à hauteur de 1000 euros par an
qui auparavant ne bénéficiez de
strictement rien qui ont permis par
ailleurs d'augmenter de 800 euros par an
les bourses de ceux aux revenus les plus
faibles ou encore de verser à 2000
étudiants une allocation d'autonomie de
4000 euros par an lorsqu'ils sont en
rupture familiale avéré alors madame la
députée oui notre politique est
ambitieuse parce que nous avons pour
ambition d'amener 50 % d'une classe
d'âge à être diplômés de l'enseignement
supérieur
dans ce cadre nous avons décidé à la
fois d'élargir le nombre de
bénéficiaires des bourses et de
continuer à donner un coup de pouce à
ceux qui ont fait des efforts en effet
les mentions très bien continueront à
percevoir 900 euros de plus par an
pendant trois ans le mérite et la
réussite du plus grand nombre c'est
conciliables
mais